many libertarian men are fairly ignorant
about women's issues some of them are
outright hostile to feminism because
they've never bothered to find out what
it is
hi i'm tim cavanaugh a recent TV sharon
Presley is a foundational figure in the
libertarian movement she's the
co-founder of less a fair books she is
currently the executive director of the
Association of libertarian feminists and
resources for independent thinking she's
the author of countless books most
recently standing up to experts and
authorities Sharon thank you for glad to
be here since I remember reason from the
time it was a mimeograph sheet can you
give us a little idea of what
libertarian feminism is well like other
kinds of feminism we believe that women
should be judged as individuals and not
on the basis of their gender and we
believe that gender stereotypes have
gotten in the way of both men and women
to simply be the individuals they want
to be but the difference between
libertarian feminism and other kinds of
feminism so we just don't think that the
state is very helpful in achieving that
end and that we need to achieve that and
through means that are consistent with
our goals if our goal is to get rid of
patriarchy then we have to get rid of
government patriarchy as well as family
patriarchy in your view as the movement
moved forward or are we still where we
were it has moved forward obviously
there are a lot more people who call
themselves libertarians today and the
word libertarian actually appears in the
news from time to time which was
certainly rarely the case in the 70s so
that's the good news and there are all
kinds of organizations that have sprung
up since then and the promoting
libertarian ideas how about in terms of
impact I mean do you see more ideas of
you know in on anything taxation or
individual liberty or obviously Ron Paul
is having an impact even though I don't
consider him a hundred percent
libertarian by any means but he has
brought new people into the
he had a best-seller however it's my
personal belief that the libertarian
movement is really not gonna go too far
forward till they get a better idea of
how to appeal to the average person
because the average person doesn't give
a flying handshake about theory or or
Austrian economics now obviously as
libertarians we don't want to throw our
principles out the window but I think we
need to learn how to appeal to the
average person you've dealt a lot with
women's issues I see on Facebook often
exercised about women's issues and just
in right now what what would what could
libertarians do to become less of the
you know the the man sitting in his
panel den kind of party that or not part
of a movement
well III do think that it's better than
it used to be because because there are
more women involved but many libertarian
men are fairly ignorant about women's
issues some of them are outright hostile
to feminism because they've never
bothered to find out what it is this the
curious thing libertarians know better
than to believe what they read in the
media about libertarianism but somehow
some of them believe what they read in
the media about feminism hello
that's not very consistent it's not
critical thinking what do you think of
the the popular idea it certainly you
hear about it a lot in libertarian
circles that Republicans are we're not
Republicans but they're the more natural
allies for libertarians and the
Democrats already think there's anything
to that not anymore
in the 60s that might have been true
because the Republicans weren't nutjobs
in the 60s Goldwater was perfectly
sensible even though he got a bad rap
but the people now aren't like dole
water I mean we either have the
fundamentalists who want to RAM their
personal moral values down everybody
else's throat or we got people like
Romney who's an opportunist who will
just you know go whichever way the wind
is blowing and given the influence of
the fundamentalist in the Republican
Party I wouldn't go there
in practical political terms where do
you think we
today you know we have an election
coming up we have the fight over the
individual mandate I mean there's a lot
of stuff that's seen you know in actual
politics we're seeing a government
trying to get bigger and and real
arguments over the size and role of
government I'm a short-term pessimist
and perhaps a long-term optimist a
short-term pessimist because as you say
just every time you turn around so some
new incredible invasion of our rights
that the founders certainly weren't
perfect themselves but nonetheless the
founders would have been dumbfounded out
and people just go along with it so
there's very dangerous trends because
the Democrats want to control us one way
and the Republicans want to control us
another and it's gotten more extreme so
in the short run I think it's things are
kind of bleak but in the long run we
have the internet which is has already
made an impact in terms of letting
people have information that will help
them to act in a way that may make them
freer and and I and also people in
societies change a lot of people I get
this constantly on Facebook saying Oh
that'll never happen
150 years ago things were much much
different than they are now women were
very restricted Victorian moral values
were in full force now that just isn't
the case
I personally firmly believe that the
directional and materialism in general
has to go is to work on creating
sustaining maintaining building
alternatives because we can't just say
government is bad you know people are
people know government's bad but they
say but what else can we do we have to
show them by example because theory is
just not going to convince most people
it just isn't
you have to say here's the way these
things have worked could work and are
now working terrific well thank you very
much for joining us
Sharon Presley straight for recent TV I
am Tim cabinet